so high whose episode 9 of this let's
play never thought I would actually get
this far and I'm kind of pissed off
because first of all my throat hurts
some stupid reason and then last episode
Sony Vegas decided to [ __ ] me over
a couple of times and add some nice
little black screens and [ __ ] yes ah
renderer errors but it took me three
hours to render it so I'm not going to
re-render it so deal with it and then
the code master given gave me a cool CTR
it's a pillar coaster kiss Villa Costa
CTR that's no wheels but whoever gives
you [ __ ] huh it's a pillow coaster but
then I test it and then frankly it
doesn't work [ __ ] off
so yeah what to do now I have no clue
let's finish this [ __ ] what's that let's
add a little attraction in here by the
way I just I just noticed something this
coaster doesn't even have a [ __ ] Q
line and nope yeah it's not really space
for that so screw it I'm going to build
something yep I'm doing this yeah I
should get more [ __ ] I mean I've already
used a troika then there's this little
chair swing I'm afraid this won't do any
good
alright I am way too inexperienced when
it comes to parks and CFR's and all that
kind of stuff huh and I can't go round
place airplanes here force my classical
Park not stupid but then again what am I
going to do with a pirate ship flying
elephants that [ __ ] doesn't even make
sense
insanity hmm how about an insanity oh
wow that thing is monstrous oh yeah
that's just the way I like him
No there was there was no intended
sexual or if that's a little bit too
close to [ __ ] off it's a little bit too
close to the path so moving this one I
think this should be good around here
and this is the entrance if I'm not
mistaken and here's going to be in exits
just a small little exit now I'm gonna
start off with making an invisible path
speaking of invisible path I still need
to add some paths in here so let's do
that right away before I forget it oh
yeah unlost video somebody posted a
comment about the queue line for this
coaster and there was a good point I
kind of forgot about that's and hmm I
like the station this way so I don't
think I'll really add a queue line I
might come back on that later because
it's not really realistic this way but
that's me I'm stupid I keep forgetting
things diagonals are a pain in the ass
but other than that path work is okay
it's not as bad as supporting a wooden
coaster whoo I [ __ ] up over here
didn't I
I'm going to get rid of that so I can
add a little bit of path right here
don't worry I'll get rid of the weird
terraforming going on right now oh yeah
and last video I also asked about
whether people prefer real-time footage
or time lapses and still it's kind of an
unfinished debate because there's people
on both sides and there's arguments for
both of course because you do learn a
lot more well sorry learn anything from
me mumbling it is sometimes somewhat
very interesting I guess it can be when
I'm talking instead of just playing
music and learning a time lapse run but
then again whenever I'm talking in this
game I just mumble like an idiots
so yeah that's not really the perfect
situation for me but whatever you guys
want before I started this les play I
was like skeptical as anybody can be
because this is a like a skill tree like
honestly how how is anybody going to
narrate this it's the most boring piece
of crap you're ever going to play I mean
you can create cool [ __ ] and all but
it's not really game like it's not
really game that's interesting full of
action and stuff
the only thing that's here is silver at
playing this game clicking and building
stuff and it's not really interesting I
guess so
maybe I should teach you guys some more
about rocketry no never mind I don't
have anything to say I think I'm going
to add a different texture path for the
middle here because otherwise I'm using
the same texture over and over again
oh yeah that's a that's a tip do you
know do not use the same walls or paths
or anything with the same texture all
over the place it gets boring as hell
don't ever do that look I've got some
cool sets that I've never used before I
like playing with such stuff never used
before
here is a set called floors and paths
straight to the point and it's actually
usable where the hell are all the pieces
is this a cool floor hmm it's actually
pretty cool
I guess I can use it I guess I guess I
could and that's looking kind of awkward
let's see there should be some of these
weird curves in there not that it's even
got stairs oh my god the [ __ ] so
everything when a holding
this but well where's the piece that are
once ah there we go
right ah yes this is not really easy to
deal with oh it's even good yeah of
course because they have to they have to
kind of fit each other that's going to
be a song as well no please don't fit at
all no matter what I do
screw that quarter tile okay this is
this is a nope all right they're our cue
I suck that's cues you didn't even know
now this thing is still boggling my mind
oh yes of course it does that so I have
to add diagonals later on have even more
ponies and spend more time on it thank
you very much oh well the set looks cool
so uh yeah oh my god I meant to create a
somewhat helpful let's play and what do
I get me mumbling and being confused by
the simplest of custom scene resets I
feel like such a noob doing this the
quarter sixty sixteenth but wait what
holy [ __ ] that's tiny what I've never
even seen that I am confused as to why
there is not yet a penis custom scenery
set
what's this floating thing doing in
there you know they're alright so yeah
where was I q oh this is going to be
happy fun times with this custom scenery
sad lovely this is a weird Q oh well I'm
just going for it
who's going to who's going to care about
one Q anyway put a fence around it lots
of trees around it so nobody sees the
darn ugly Q and you're done with it
it's time to get my favorite sets
station gyms gardening well it's one of
my favorites oh wait I have to be in the
objects menu I mean this Sal is enormous
and it's got everything it's got benches
picnic tables even rock borders that I
love to use I think these would go
pretty well with these and there's no
need to worry about inner pieces or
outer pieces because every piece fits
everything yes aha it's inventions like
this that make my life worth it okay so
this thing is almost finished now I just
have to well look whatever fence I'm
going to use for this because I have no
idea
now this looks weird from from the
aerial view perspective but I'm pretty
sure that from ground level or look okay
all right station Jim it's your turn
again for your fences more fencing now
we're going to use these fences because
they're awesome now I just have to get
some pickets posts bigger posts make it
boasts big nose most big yeah of course
I had to forget one piece of offense
I always forget everything I can forget
that's me
and I always misplace things as well
that's me as well and my crappy Mouse
there I do it again ah now I'm going to
surround this Fame with a nice little
border from CTRs paths to because it's
amazing and this set goes pretty well
with all the other sites that I'm using
so I'm it's all good
hang on lemme time-lapse for a little
bit
I have seen killer bees
we'll attack anything that moves
anything that makes noise matters
they will kill anything
very well then this is all finished now
and yeah I've done that much but I've
got this little insanity thing with all
the paths around it right now and this
area is almost finished now and I think
next episode I'm just going to add a few
more finishing touches like a couple of
buildings and stuff so um that'll be it
for them so see you next episode